へいへい
あああああ
皆さんこんにちは私はイオンで
csr を担当しておりますが昔から環境の世界で仕事をしてきたわけでも環境の専門
家というわけでもありません
ですから4年前2017年に着任したときはパリ協定
聞いたことあるけど暗いなぁ認識でしたでもその11月にドイツのボンで開催された
気候変動に関する国際会議
コップ23を視察することになって私の考え方は大きく変わったんです
そのドイツで参加した会議の一つがこちらになります
当時国連気候変動を組み組条約の事務局長としてパリ協定の締結に多大な貢献をされた
クリスティーナフィゲル s さんとの対話ですこの対話には日本企業から代表団に
加えてか
環境省それから外務省の担当者の方もいらしてました
フィギア資産はここで気候変動の深刻さそしてパリ協定の大切さ
その意義を熱く語られました
そして最後にこう締めくくられたのです
日本の皆さん皆さんの国は世界でも最も高い技術力の日
いうする国の一つです
日本はとっても経済力もあり豊かです
その日本がなぜ気候変動
この地球の危機といわれる気候変動の問題にもっと貢献をしてくれないんでしょうか
この分野でもっとリーダーシップを発揮してほしいんですとそう冬さんはいいました
私は日本はその当時まだ日本は環境でイケてる国なの一つだというふうに思っていたの
で正直日本人としてショックでした
帰国して何ができるのか企業として何をすべきか考えました
イオンでは早くから環境問題に関しては先駆的な取り組みを続けてきました
これを見せしているのはショッピンセンターですがこのショッピングセンターの上に
乗っている全部ソーラーパネルですこういうふうに西へで投資もそれから省エネ投資も
ものすごく早い段階から一生懸命してきましたがそのおかげで
ずっと事業規模は拡大を続けているんですけれども
co2の排出量はグループ送料でずーっと減らすことができています
でもこの段階ではまだ一生懸命企業努力で低炭素社会を目標として努力をしていると
いうレベルなんです
私が見たポップでコップ23で見た世界は
大きくステージが変わっていました低炭素社会ではなくもう立つ炭素社会なんだとそう
いうふうに計会議に打って翌年の2018年の3月にイオン立つ炭素ビジョン2050
を発表することができました今年の10月には菅総理大臣が日本でも
10年ネットゼロ社会を宣言してくれました
大変素晴らしいことですこれでようやく
いつまでにどこへ行かなければいけないのかというゴールが日本の国\全体で共有でき
たことになります
でも実はもっと大切なことがあるんですその共有されたゴールに向かってどの道を通っ
てどうやって進むのかというこの計画の部分が大切なんです
2050年に練ってゼロというゴールにたどり着ければいいのではないかと思いがちな
んですけれども実は気温上昇というのは co2の累積排出量に比例するということが
わかっていますつまりこの頭の中のこの面積部分が重要になります
この面積が小さければ小さいほど
気温上昇を低く抑えることができるというふうに言われています
たとえこのもし仮にこの赤い道を辿ったとしたら
2050年に仮に立つ炭素が実現できていたとしてももうすでにその時点では
1.5度を超えてしまっている世界になっている可能性があるということです
それを踏まえて読んでも目標に向かってどうやってたどり着くのかということを考え
ました
最初はやっぱり省エネですこれは今までもやってきましたがこれからもずっと継続して
手を緩めることなく投資をしていかなければなりません2つ目
創エネ先ほど写真を見せしましたソーラーパネルが載っていました
今現在で日本全国のイオングループで1戦店舗ぐらいのテンポには載っている計算に
なりますがそれでも足りません
まだやはりどこからかさ屋根を買ってこないとダメなのです
イオンでは年間に85億 kw の電気を消費しています
これは日本全国の電力消費量の1%に相当しますでも逆に言うとたったの1%です
日本全国から再エネを買ってくることもできますし
非化石証書でそれ充当させるということも可能ですでもそれではダメなんです
特定の企業だけが自社のまあ資金力があるからもしくは環境意識が高いからという理由
で
自社の環境目標を達成することができたとしても地球の気候危機を回避することができ
ません
ではどうしたらいいのでしょうか
普通に電源にコンセントが電源差し込んだ時にそこに流れてくる電気が
菜園になっているような世界に変えていかなければいけないんです
でこの電源を差し込んで流れてくる電気が何から作られていいのか
どんな原材料で作られているのかというのがこのペン件ミックスです
今2019年の段階で電源構成は日本では化石燃料を由来が
な10%を超えるというふうに言われています
皆さん食品をスーパーで買うとき原材料を気にしますよね
この食べ物には何が入っているのかどんな添加物でどこでつくらい原産国はどこなのか
気にしますよね
電源も同じだと思うんです電源も気にされますか
いえ気にしてほしいんですねで
それを声に出してくださいイオンでは毎日毎日お客様からこんな商品がほしい
こんな品揃えをしてほしいということを言われますそれに応えて事業者は品揃えしたり
事業を行っているわけです
電源も同じです声に出して欲しいんです
私たちはそれを目的として日本紀行リーダーズパートナーシップという組織を立ち上げ
ております
この組織には今現在160社の日本の企業が加盟をしていただいてます
ここでみんなでどんなもっと再生可能エネルギーを買いたい
そういう社会にしてほしい
c ということを訴えています
2030年に化石燃料を40%以下に抑えなければ基本上昇を1.5度以内に抑える
ことができないというふうに言われています
欧州の主要国では再エネの比率を50から65%に引き上げるという目標を立ててい
ます
こちらが今日本政府が掲げている2030年の目標です本当にこれでいいのでしょうか
もちろん課題はたくさんあります電力系統の問題大きな問題です
誰が投資するのか原発をエネルギーをどうするのか
簡単な問題ではありません国家安全上の問題にもなります
でも一つ分かっているのは2030年にいわゆる再生可能エネルギー太陽光ソーラー
solar 水力地熱そういったもので日本の全需要の50%をまかなうこと
は技術的に可能だというふうに言われていますあとは本気で行動を起こすかどうかだけ
ですぜひこの問題は国や政府
それから電気を作る側の人だけではなくって使う側の人たち
企業もそれから一般の正してもみんなでこの問題をどうしたらいいのか考え
ていくべきだというふうに思います